Hey, welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. I'm Darrell Stetler.
Grab your workbook, and if you don't have one, go to 40daysofholiness.com
and get yours, okay? Here's today's theme, day
five. Jesus is the perfect
human expression of holiness. It's one
thing to talk about God being holy and dwelling in
unapproachable light. It's one thing to talk about him being separate from
creation, higher, better, more pure than we can
possibly imagine.
But what would it look like if God injected
his holiness into the created realm and people,
someone, became holy? Is human holiness even possible?
Yes, it absolutely is. You see, God became man and in the
person of Jesus Christ. This is incredibly valuable for us because it
allows us to define what perfect human holiness
looks like. We'll never have infinite power or
be uncreated. We will never have infinite presence and be
everywhere. We'll never know everything, but God never called us to do
that. But he did call us to be holy.
So what does it look like for a human to be holy?
And the answer is it looks exactly like Jesus.
Nothing more, nothing less. Holiness is
Christlikeness. If someone asks you during this 40
days of focus on holiness, "What are you seeking for?
What are you looking for?" Here's the simple answer:
I'm seeking to find out how much of Jesus God can produce in me
during this life.
I'm seeing how much like Jesus I can be in my life, my heart, my
mind, my attitudes. Maximum holiness
equals maximum Christlikeness. Now, some denominations
and Bible teachers within the Christian tradition will not agree with
everything I'm going to teach you in this 40 days.
Some of them would tell you that things like, "Well, reaching perfection in
this world is just not possible." And I partly agree, depending
on how you define perfection. Some of your family or friends might not agree,
right? Some of the most common phrases in every worldly person's
theology is, "Nobody's perfect."
But that's only partially true. I can't
teach people how to reach total human perfection, where you never make a
mistake, or you never stumble, you never misunderstand, you
never get tired, never regret, never have to apologize and go back and
say, "I'm sorry."
But I'm not teaching you any perfection that would mean you cannot
improve or you cannot grow. That's not what we're looking for.
Instead, I want to encourage you to seek this and
only this,
to maximize the amount of Jesus likeness you have in your
heart and life.
So if you've been seeking anything more than Jesus likeness, Christlikeness,
adjust your expectations. If you've been seeking anything less
than full Jesus likeness, Christlikeness, change that today
because he's the standard of what human holiness looks like.
When he calls you to "follow me," he's saying, "Follow me
into holiness."
So today, let's just focus our minds and our hearts on
Jesus and say, "Jesus, what can you do in me today?
What can you do in me during this time to produce
the holiness, the Christlikeness, the full amount of the measure and the
stature of Jesus that you can produce in my heart and life?" All right.
That's what we're looking for together.
Thanks for being here. Make sure you take time to do the workbook.
If you haven't downloaded it and printed it out, we're still just five days into
this 40-day journey. Get a hold of that book, all right?
Get a hold of that workbook, 40daysofholiness.com.
Print it out if you haven't already. Do the exercises.
Don't skip them, all right? And spend the time, meditate on it, pray
over it, and I'll see you back here tomorrow. Thanks for being here.